[Applause]
all right let's finish up with something
funny discovered on social media this is
what I'm
liking so this car is an elementary
school teacher in Indiana inviting her
boyfriend to be the mystery reader for
her class the second graders were
mesmerized by his words but the teacher
had no idea the book had a surprise
twist at the ending check it out now
there is something still
missing yes just one thing a beautiful
radiant cut diamond
[Music]
ringel here I
am so cool we have the Happy coule on
the line right now watching on WTH HR in
Indianapolis let's let's say hi to
Rachel and Austin
everybody that was such a cool way to do
it Austin do you think that Rachel were
you more surprised or the kids the kids
were squealing yeah the kids were
squealing it's hard to say because I had
told Austin that I wanted a private
proposal just me and him so the entire
time um I think they picked up on it way
before me because the whole entire time
I'm thinking there's no way he's going
to do this like he just being really
sweet in front of my kids and it wasn't
until he dead I'm missing just one thing
I was like oh this is really about to
happen right now like he's about to pull
out a ring so I don't know I think was
AA and Austin did you write the book
that you were reading yeah so uh the
strike zone is an Austin Dunwoody
original actually uh wrote it in my
Prime in third grade um the point of the
book uh as third graders think I
actually turned into a bowling pen in
the book sure um and I had to add one
special character which was the shiny
head pin at the front of the lane which
ended up being Rachel and I brought that
out at the poem right at the end of the
video oh my God it's so great it's so
awesome too because kids learning about
love like my daughter would have been
the loudest Squealer in that room she
loves love so much but that was so cool
that you shared it with them too what a
special moment for all of you thank you
for sharing it I'm liking your post
right now right thank you so much all
right well that's not all our season
long partner pilot pin make us a precise
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate your engagement with
you so they're giving you $1,000 you can
put that wherever you
want congratulations you two thank you
to all our guests this hour edar Ramirez
Stevie dener Danny deito Victoria
Justice and Toby gag you have a great
it's
not
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home